foreign
studying syntax to being an NLP
researcher so starting out I was very
interested in human languages and how
they work how people understand them I
did have interest in computer science
and so my interests were kind of mixed
but I ended up at Stanford as a
linguistic student at that point in the
early 90s things were just starting to
change when they first started to be
lots of human language material text and
speech available digitally so this was
just before the World Wide Web exploded
and it just seemed really clear that
there had to be exciting things that you
could do by working empirically from
lots of human language and that's what
really sort of got me involved in a new
kind of natural language processing that
then led into my subsequent career
[Music]